your setbacks prime your comebacks
nobody's on top always it says drop and
then you come back even higher and so
whatever you want to go off and do
whatever change you want to go off and
make chances are one it's not fatal you
can always come back to something if you
want to take a year off after University
to go be an entrepreneur instead of
going to that job or if you're if you're
in a job that you hate you say you know
what I can always get another job so I'm
going to try for a year doing my own
business it's not fatal you can always
come back and do it you can always come
back and get that crappy job you know
you're capable of it you know you're
probably more than capable of it of what
you're doing right now